hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 7 video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it there
were so many reveals probably the best
episode of the season so far so here we
go
I was surprised by so many things in
this episode you know first like the big
kiss they haven't done that since season
1 and that was every man that kissed her
so for those asking yes this is
something from the comics but here let's
do top 10 WTF because we had all this
avatar the doctor alchemy stuff so here
we go number 10 the flash versus Savitt
are just completely takes him for a ride
he looks like a full-blown transformer
when they do like the full wide shot of
him but he takes Barry through what
looks like Speed Force portals like he's
literally running inside the Speed Force
just popping up all over town
simultaneously or that's the way it
looks - Cisco and the other people so
when he's running through this blue
tunnel here I think that's him running
through the Speed Force and at the end
of the episode you know number 9 he asks
alchemy to help him come back so here's
where the writer of the episode did a
really good job of tying the storylines
together Wally West is stuck in this
in-between state where his body can't
really handle what's going on to him I
think that's what's also going on with
Savitt are where he's kind of like half
stuck inside the Speed Force
so he's super fast he has white
lightning like that's how fast he is so
he has these crazy powers but he can't
fully manifest inside the world that's
why he needs Alchemy's help to get back
so that is a bit of a twist on comic
books avatar who did get stuck inside
the Speed Force but it was a little more
straight-up like Wally West in the past
defeats him by trapping him inside the
Speed Force but then later he escapes in
Barry Allen ends up killing him
accidentally so the story the TV shows
going with it just a little different
trapped in the Speed Force trying to get
out alla flash rebirth Geoff Johns not
the new flash rebirth but the old flash
rebirth but number 8 Caitlin's powers
are totally effective against him she
can also leech energy so that might come
in handy later too but she just helps
them see him she also slows him down
just a little bit so just remember that
fight because those skills will come in
handy later because in the comics the
flash was not able to defeats avatar
without the help of other speedsters
it's the same thing with God
speed too so like you have to have team
flash all working together in order to
defeat him and it sounds like that's
what they're kind of teasing force
avatar like he's so hardcore
there's no way Barry stands a chance
without the help of the rest of team
flash so number seven though as a
consequence of helping him caitlin
starts to go full-blown killer frost
only the version they're going with on
the TV show is kind of in between like
everybody's in between wall is in
between sabotage in between caitlin is
halfway in between
killer frost and caitlin snow so the way
the producers teased her is they said
they were calling her caitlin frost so
she has the powers of killer frost but
she still has the heart in the mind of
Caitlin snow which is why she gets super
scientific when she's using her powers
like she stabs Barry in the exact right
place that'll disable him for four hours
without killing him but the
interrogation scene so this was so great
number six Joe and Caitlin both go super
hardcore like Joe crabs him I just love
this version of him like last year when
he clocked Harrison wells like ain't
taking no Joe and then later
Caitlin does the exact same thing
maybe you should fear me now so number
five she steals Julianne and we see Greg
Grunberg who's actually doing like a
guest spot because Kevin Smith is
directing the episode Greg Grunberg
also has done a lot of sci-fi stuff like
Star Trek you know alias a whole bunch
of sci-fi but he also has a TV show with
Kevin Smith called geeking out so I
wonder if Kevin Smith asked them
specially to get Greg in the episode get
him like a cameo but it was really fun
seeing him so Kaelyn takes Julianne and
you have like the scientific version of
killer frost asking him to make an
algorithm so they can track down alchemy
using his followers this is why you
clear your browser history when you join
a speed cult because they're searching
for people that have been searching the
internet for Savitt are so let that be a
lesson to you but number four full-blown
killer frost versus vibe just like Cisco
saw in his vision surprised twist
Snowberry kiss for all you shippers out
there I was just blown away that they
actually did that but she does do it in
the comics so it's a comic book twist
but you can laugh about it because of
what happened during season one with
everyman they had that weird awkward
kiss this was way cooler because it got
super
boogy berry just goes super blue like
that's how cold II was so it was like a
funny moment just you know because of
who they are but they also did in a
really cool comic book way but then one
of my favorite caitlin scenes came right
after this when she is just super savage
waking up in the pipeline
she just rips into all of them i just
laughed so hard on how much she opened
up on them savage as hell but she also
creates that huge rift with cisco now
they're playing it super ambiguous too
so yeah I mean Cisco and Barry will be
friends again but they just don't want
it to automatically go back to normal
right away
same thing with number three Wally
coming out of the cocoon so like I said
one of the themes of the episode was
people being this in-between state are
you good are you evil it's not a binary
thing like Barry's speech at the end so
Wally comes out of the cocoon and his
body can't handle the changes so they
have to go help him out but it also
provides this you know really emotional
scene with Caitlin where she comes back
from the brink because she can't kill
Barry so that's your answer to future
killer Frost's on the show we're gonna
see Caitlin Frost she'll probably lose
her every once in a while but
she'll still be a core member of the
team she'll still be a series regular so
she's gonna be in most of the episodes
in number two now that she's kind of
back to normal she's able to help them
fix Wally so he has that really awesome
scene where he's running around he's
faster than Barry when Barry first had
his accident
but even though it's all hopeful yeah
that really sad moment with Julianne
where he makes Barry quit they even had
like the Easter Egg where he's walking
out and everything's really sad and you
hear that bolt of lightning just making
you remember when he first got his
powers so never fear I totally think
that he will be back in that lab before
the end of the season but big twist
number one Julianne is revealed as dr.
alchemy in them maybe not surprising
twist I think a lot of people were
expecting it because Julianne Albert
Albert Desmond dr. alchemy the second
version of the character worked in the
CSI lab with Barry so like there were a
couple clues pointing to him possibly
being alchemy but the real question now
is how aware of alchemy is Julianne is
it like a split personality situation or
is it like Caitlin where like her brain
just goes a little bit nuts when she's
in killer frost mode so she's not
thinking
clearly we you know we don't know how
much Julian is complicit with dr.
alchemy like is this a cosplay situation
or is it straight-up split personalities
like it was in the comics but we got to
talk about savat are like there's so
much going on here so like he has that
crazy mouth like when he opens up I
still think that it's a person
underneath there somewhere but he says
he's the future
you're the past the acolytes said that
he showed them all the future I saw you
it was glorious
you are killer frost so is sabot are
from the future like did he come from
the future to the Past to try and take
over or is he somebody from the present
who has seen the future because he got
speedforce powers and is trying to like
bring about this future outcome so there
is actually a new 52 future flash
storyline where future flash Barry Allen
comes back to kill himself in the past
to prevent a bunch of bad stuff from
happening this doesn't seem like that
but I might do like a separate video for
future flash to explain that because it
is an interesting twist
but like the reverse flash is also a
time traveler who came back into the
past to try and change the future so
whatever's happened saboteur is trapped
in like this in-between state but he has
all this power it needs alchemy to help
bring him back fully so the real thing
now is in figuring out what Julian is
going to do about dr. alchemy in what's
avatars real plan is like what he's
actually going to do to bring himself
back so it was a great character episode
great twist comic book episode like
great WTF moment big action set piece
episode 2 so I feel like the script was
better the action was better the
characters were better so hands down
favorite episode this season so far
we'll see if the four-way crossover or
the mid-season finale can top it it's
going to be really hard to top but let
me know what was your favorite moment
was this your favorite episode of the
season so far it was fun with all the
flashpoint stuff in the beginning and
you can kind of tell they wanted to
slowly weave savitur in he was there
from the beginning like he killed the
rival at the end of episode 2 so he's
always been around but they really
wanted to establish the new speedsters
like Jesse quick Wally West it like
explained those concepts so that people
understood tease out dr. alchemy so he
seems like a really big deal and even
like the big twist with the rival to
like look at this big boss who doesn't
matter
at all because we killed him off in the
second episode that was a really fun
twist where he have like the super evil
guy come kill the other person that you
think is supposed to be the main villain
just to show you how badass he is but a
lot of you might have noticed that
sabotage voice still sounds like Tobin
Bell so when we hear alchemy speak and
we think it's Tobin Bell maybe somehow
he's replicating sabotage voice but for
those of you asking yes that is Tobin
Bell who is speaking when we hear
sabotage speaking so the only other real
big Easter eggs that I spotted in the
episode was the Game of Thrones shout
out don't go all mother dragons on me
with the hair when Sisko is talking to
Caitlin
they're the wall-e thing with him being
faster than Barry was at the beginning
is also a comic book thing because comic
book Wally West was the fastest version
of the flash so we'll see how fast Wally
gets eventually but this is like just
the beginning for his character and when
a charge says Barry's superpower is hope
that's also a comic book thing Barry
even became a part of the Blue Lantern
Corps which harnessed the blue light of
hope during the war of light so really
cool nod to that but also probably the
smartest thing that's ever come out of
that HR character's mouth so despite not
being a scientist he actually does have
some emotional intelligence in him
somewhere and I'm really curious to see
if we ever see Caitlin put on some kind
of comic book looking costume because
they made that but they only used it in
the flash for like the potential future
where she's fighting Cisco as full-blown
killer frost really important stuff
though next week is the big four night
crossover it's going to be purely
dominators but they might lightly touch
on this dr. alchemist avatar stuff so
we'll say congratulations to this week's
DC giveaway winner David Grace you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round that starts now I'll just
go ahead and start around now but if
there's any like special bonus videos on
killer frost or any other concepts like
future flash just let me know in the
comments because there's a lot of really
cool comic book stuff happening here but
the TV show as it tends to do is mixing
and matching things but there is like a
bunch of comic book stuff happening
tomorrow there's no new episode of arrow
but Kevin Feige did this big Marvel vs.
DC Explo
where you know he was talking about the
Marvel films they've been making what DC
is doing why they're probably not going
to be able to make a deal with Fox
anytime soon for the x-men characters so
I'll do a video for that next but
there's also been some talk of carnage
showing up in the spider-man Marvel
movies so I'll do a video for that too
and then obviously we got some new
footage for the big four night crossover
so a whole bunch of marvel and DC post
thing I'll try to get that out as fast
as possible well you guys wait for it to
post you can click here for my god speed
versus avatar video and you can click
here for the trailer for the big 4 night
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you